Roger stone was an advisor to Donald
Trump's presidential campaign he was a
longtime associate and business partner
Paul Manafort
and he joins us tonight Roger thank you
for coming on what is this about the
imprisonment of Paul Manafort well it's
about pressuring man afford to plead
guilty so that the government doesn't
have to go to trial it's interesting
that the government refuses to turn over
to Manta for in discovery any
information gleaned through surveillance
in fact they insist that he was never
under surveillance not prior to the
Trump campaign not during the Trump
campaign even though numerous mainstream
media organizations have reported
otherwise that's because he was most
likely subject to a illegal
unconstitutional FISA warrant according
to the New York Times I was also subject
to a FISA warrant in June of 2016
reported by The Times On January 20th
2016 and I've just filed Freedom of
Information Act requests to get to the
bottom of that well wait a second if the
New York Times can discover that you're
being spied upon by the government why
can't you ascertain whether that's
happening or not well there's a process
first you have to put in a governmental
information request once the
government's had a certain amount of
time to respond then you can file a
lawsuit
both tort suit and a suit against
individuals say John Brennan Susan Rice
and others mr. clapper and I intend to
do that but in the meantime Tucker it's
become abundantly clear that having come
up empty-handed of any evidence of
Russian collusion having no proof of any
high jinks with WikiLeaks because I
received nothing from them and passed
nothing on it's now abundantly clear
that the special counsel seeks to go
through every aspect of my personal
business and political life try to
conjure up some offense to pressure me
to testify against the president it's
Orwellian it's the police state I'm
being persecuted because I supported
Donald Trump but let me let me just back
up for a second we are told we're often
told that the bar for a FISA warrant is
really high I mean you have to
demonstrate that someone is
in effect betraying his country what
would be the pretext upon which the
Muller people would have gotten a FISA
warrant to spy on you well in fact the
US citizen can only be subject to a FISA
warrant if they're actively involved in
espionage on behalf of a foreign power
against the United States clearly FISA
warrants were used by the Obama
administration for political purposes
this is a scandal that makes Watergate
look like second-rate burglary
are the people around you getting drawn
into this that's the extraordinary thing
Tucker Associates of mine as many as 12
of them have been subpoenaed have been
questioned aggressively by the FBI some
of them are fighting those subpoenas
it's unclear what it is the government
wants other than to find somebody who
will bear false witness against Roger
stone it's a witch hunt and it's a very
expensive witch hunt this is costing me
hundreds of thousands of dollars on top
of the lawsuits filed against me by the
Democratic National Committee and some
Obama affiliated groups I've had to set
up a legal defense fund at Stone Defense
Fund dot-com Stone Defense Fund dot-com
because it threatens to bankrupt me
which is exactly the point they seek to
drag your name through the mud and to
ruin you financially so we can't
administer a polygraph
obviously in live television but just I
want to end on this and for the record
have you ever worked on behalf of any
foreign power against the interest of
the United States government absolutely
positively not look I am an American
whose rouses were crushed in Budapest in
the 50s by Russian tanks this is an
absurd notion and it is an abysmal state
of affairs where we have a partisan
special prosecutor seeking a crime where
it none exists you better have betrayed
the country or else someone owes you a
big apology I would say Roger stone
thank you